hello everybody I'm back for another
vlog today and if you were following me
like a couple of weeks maybe like a
month or so back on social media you may
have seen that I need some kind of like
very very subdued announcement that I
was going to be taking a little bit of a
break from social media for an undecided
amount of time I also kind of briefly
mentioned that this was one of the
strategies that I was putting into place
to help with my insomnia and if you
haven't watched my insomnia video I
talked a little bit more about that and
the outcome in that video so definitely
check that out but here on Abby's
kitchen on the channel you know we talk
so much all the time about the
importance of having a healthy
relationship with food and well this has
been going really well for me personally
in my own personal life I did find that
I was having and finding a little bit of
a disconnect at managing my own
relationship with other aspects of my
life
mainly technology social media and
ultimately my work so today I wanted to
share why I decide to delete my social
media apps and also talk a little bit
about what I learned from this
experience and I don't know maybe give
you guys some inspiration for some New
Year's resolutions that don't involve
dieting okay so feel a little bit
vulnerable but I think it's important to
talk about these things
well 2019 has been a difficult year for
me I know I talked about that in my
insomnia video but yeah it's not been
easy and the fact that I have not been
sleeping well and I've been dealing with
a insomnia since like April has totally
just perpetuated every tiny little
problem that I've encountered this year
now none of those stresses per se have
been directly because of social media
but I've always struggled with kind of
high-functioning anxiety and there is a
strong evidence link between social
media use and you know feelings of
depression and social isolation so I do
think that sometimes social media has
kind of just like pushed me over the
edge
and then you know a few months ago I
think it's safe to say that I like
totally just burned out you know I hear
all the time from like friends and
family about how put together I look but
I really want to be transparent that
sometimes like that could not be farther
from the truth
that is just not reality folks and you
know my job while while working in the
media and blogging and youtubing and
making videos is like so much fun I love
my job and I'm so grateful for the
opportunities that I get to to put these
skills and my passion to use it is
really being hard to be in the public
eye all the time like really hard so my
job obviously is and always has been so
intimately tied to social media like I'm
I never off-the-grid
right like I never get a holiday I never
just get to punch out at the end of the
day or like tune everything out and
while a lot of you guys get to use
Instagram or YouTube for like
entertainment it is intimately tied up
in my own work and my own like
experience of success but like just
being online on Facebook and Instagram
and Twitter and YouTube all day long and
like you know feeling like you got to
respond to comments constantly and
always be checking up on things I I do
love it but it is so mentally exhausting
some days some days when you're already
tired and you're already down it's a lot
you know there's just so much pressure
on so-called influencers to always be
creating more content and better content
and constantly responding immediately as
if we can work all hours of the day it
doesn't matter if it's 2:00 in the
morning it weren't so response and we
can't slow down or else there's this
fear that we will just become obsolete
and no this actually has very little to
do with trolls for those of you who went
are wondering I actually have a pretty
level head about trolls and some days
when I'm feeling really good like I
always see it as a bit of a compliment
that somebody would spend you know hours
or days
like weeks out of there timed halfway
around the world thinking and talking
about me so that doesn't really bother
me all that much so while I totally get
it and I hear from influencers all the
time how you know emotionally exhausting
and devastating it can be to have to
deal with the public scrutiny at least
for me you know when I'm thinking with
the level head and not my insomnia
thoughts at 3:00 in the morning
it the trolls really don't usually
bother me all that much what I am
struggling with however is learning how
to just be enough you know how can i how
can I learn to just do what I can today
put it away until tomorrow and not let
my otherwise like amazing life be
overshadowed by my overwhelming drive to
just keep producing and more and making
more and working harder so honestly I
was just feeling like I needed to really
get my sleep under control get my
general anxiety under control and find a
better balance as my family and my
business grows you know I really would
love for my son to have a sibling one
day but I knew that that was just never
going to happen if I didn't prioritize
my well-being and ya know like getting
my sleep under control so that I wasn't
just gonna end up burning out and then
like crying all day like it's just not
productive
so as this like brave attempt at
self-care I decided to delete my social
media apps on my phone kind of is a bit
of an experiment to see what would
happen but also as a way to just give
myself a little bit of like
psychological rest I know that seems
like so easy and also kind of like so
silly even to be talking about or
thinking about but let's be honest with
ourselves like most Millennials are
completely addicted to their phones and
their social media apps not to mention I
like depend on these things for my work
as well it's not just entertainment to
me so honestly it was like a really hard
big pill to try to swallow so let's talk
about what happened
so for the first like week or so I found
myself constantly like picking up my
phone checking for notifications like
swiping up to see what was going to be
able to give me a little bit of a
dopamine hit and when there wasn't
anything there because all those social
media apps were gone and like emails
kind of boring it's just work would be
coming my way which is never fun I felt
this like gaping hole which was really
an interesting realization for me so I
had of like boredom I guess in
desperation for something on my phone I
ended up downloading like a bunch of
crossword apps and little games to play
just something to like keep my mind and
hands and stuff busy but just weird I
ended up looking at a lot of photos like
scrolling through photos making dinner
reservations or like looking at dinner
reservations for date nights I just like
don't have time for I don't know a
babysitter for what else was I doing
oh I was like going on like shopping
stores like online shopping stores and
like Amazon Bank Lee didn't buy too much
I was worried about that but yeah it is
amazing what a habit it is for us to
constantly holding and looking at our
phone and this little experiment here
really proved that to me so after seven
days or so I found the urge to like pick
up my phone and and do something random
definitely had decreased I still
occasionally would like text somebody
totally randomly but it was definitely
not as strong a drive as what I was
experiencing in those first few days
that was surprising to me but was more
surprising and beneficial was some of
the outcomes I experienced as a result
of going through this experiment so
first of all I think I became a much
better mom now without the distraction
of like my notifications going off or
even just like the drive to pick up my
phone and look at it all the time I felt
like I was able to bond so much more
with my little 20 month old honestly I
could talk a lot more about this in
another video if you're interested
but I would say that being a working mom
has a lot of emotional ups and downs but
you know sometimes I just feel like I'm
the lowest peg on the hierarchy of my
son's preferences and and data and Teta
and grandparents are above me and I get
relegated to all the not-so-fun tasks
like you know feeding broccoli and
brushing teeth and pumping breast milk
around the clock and making appointments
and doctors appointments and playdates
and all that stuff everybody else just
gets to have fun but without my phone
there I found that the time that I did
spend with my son became so much more
intimate we played more and it there
wasn't that kind of struggle and fight
constantly over over kind of grabbing my
phone anyone that's a parent right now
who has a phone knows how obsessed they
are with these little screens but yeah
as my husband kind of pointed out the
other day he's developed a little bit of
a mummy itis situation since my little
experiment and last night we put him to
bed and like all he was saying was like
this sweet little voice mama mama I'm so
cute and I'm sure one day hearing mommy
mommy mommy mommy mommy all day is gonna
be really really annoying but like I was
cried I was just so happy to hear it in
that moment and there were other like
relationship benefits as well you know I
think I've been like way nicer to my
husband that was one also I've made a
lot better connections with my friends
like I've been texting them or calling
them not just like me Instagram friends
that you just kind of like kind of know
but I've actually been making a lot more
real plans with the people I care about
and it's been so amazingly fulfilling
I've also been way more productive you
know I don't think we realize how much
time we waste just like mindlessly
scrolling through Instagram not looking
at anything really at all but when I
checked my like screen time on my phone
it set my screen time that week compared
to the week before I did the experiment
was down by 75% that's insane
that is hours of one's life that you
could be investing in work and when you
know ultimately time is money when
you're an entrepreneur
that is really valuable stuff I mean I
would way rather spend all that extra
time with my family of course but just
to think about it that way kind of like
as a transaction was really eye-opening
to me now this is the miraculous thing I
don't know why and I don't know how but
just not feeling so plugged in really
did help me get a better sleep
I went from maybe getting like two good
nights of sleep a week to going to like
five and from just that that one change
alone it was that powerful honestly I
would never have let myself you know
look at my phone past 7:00 p.m. because
of the screen time rules and all that
stuff but just not having those social
media apps operating in the background
it just didn't leave me so hyper
stimulated by the time I was trying to
wind down and go to sleep and I wasn't
constantly worrying about what was going
on or what I was missing out on it was
life changing okay so how am i balancing
social media in my own life right now
well like I said this was ultimately an
experiment and while I totally
appreciate that a lot of people go and
have these social media Detox's and they
realize like how much they hate social
media I actually realized that
ultimately I still really like it I love
the like storytelling aspect of it and I
also really love the genuine
interactions with all of you but I also
knew that I really did need to set some
boundaries so after two weeks without
any social media on my phone I decided I
need to set some you know a little bit
of a curfew with my social media usage I
ended up downloading like a dozen
different apps all promising to kind of
help one control their social media
addiction but unfortunately like none of
them did what I wanted them to do which
was ultimately to kind of kick me out
and prevent me from getting into social
media after a certain time of the day I
tried so many different ones if there's
one out there that does this please let
me know but basically what I ended up
doing instead was I set an alarm on my
phone for 5:00 p.m. and when that alarm
went off I would delete the social media
apps
from my phone and then in the morning I
could riad them and reuse them but after
5:00 p.m. I had to be off the social
media grid I did not want to be looking
I didn't want to be thinking about it
it was just for working hours so I did
this religiously for a few days and then
kind of like the novelty wore off and
the next time the next morning I read
downloaded the apps they downloaded to
the last screen on all of my you know on
my iPhone so it must mean like screen
six or seven because I've got a lot of
apps and I found that you know they just
were not so in my face as they had been
on the front page on the first page so I
just ended up using them a lot less like
my inclination my opened up my phone it
was not automatically to push Instagram
because it wasn't even there anymore
it might be my email might be text might
be music in fact music it is a lot but
it wasn't social media anymore I also so
much enjoyed that bonding that I had
with my son during the experiment so I'm
really just naturally putting my phone
down a lot more after 5 p.m. except for
like when I order a burrito I guess but
I'm really trying not to carry it around
with me as we do bedtime routine and
bath time and all that kind of stuff
just it just it's not a priority to
always be in my hand anymore so despite
a lot of the challenges that working
full-time and social media brings I'm
really making an effort to try to live
more in the moment and ultimately to
focus on my mental and emotional
well-being as we move forward into 2020
I I really don't want to burn out again
honestly I've got so many big exciting
personal and professional goals for 2020
and I really need to just devote all of
my positive energy towards meeting them
so I want to say thank you all for all
of your amazing supportive words when I
kind of went off the grid I did read all
of your DMS I got them sent to me I read
them they really helped me keep going so
I really hope that this video has been a
bit of an inspiration for helping you to
foster a healthier relationship with
technology as you move forward into 2020
so everyone I would love to hear from
you what are your thoughts on quitting
social media
or doing a social media detox so to
speak I would love to hear if this is
long you've done before how did it feel
did it work for you did you feel
refreshed afterwards also what are you
guys thinking about doing for your near
Zoar solutions that doesn't involve
dieting I'd love to hear some ideas for
that as well so if you like this video
be sure to give it the thumbs up leave
me a comment below I want to hear from
all of you subscribe to the channel and
I will see you next time on Abby's
kitchen happy near bye
[Music]